[Musique]
bonsoir à tous de par ma profession
d'ostéo j'ajuste les corps au cordeau
pour une vie sans accroc mon intention
c'est de libérer les corps des chaînes
pour en faire des roseaux souple comme
dans la fable de jean de la fontaine os
est issu mobile à 100% optimise la
diffusion du sens pour que chaque
cellule reçoive son aliment je partage
ce soir avec vous
le mode d'emploi de ce petit bijou notre
corps c'est notre machine à voyager dans
le temps
notre corps c'est notre véhicule pour
visiter le monde pour découvrir les
autres et pour se découvrir soi-même
notre corps c'est aussi l'outil que l'on
façonne chaque jour par nos choix par
nos actes et par nos gestes
pour commencer il faut bien comprendre
que notre corps a besoin d'air comme une
plante a besoin de lumière on vient au
monde par un premier cri et on le quitte
dans un dernier soupir mais avant ça je
vais vous demander à tous de dire pouce
et de lever votre pouce maintenant et de
souffler un coup
puis on vient placer son pouce sous son
sternum comme ça et on inspire on
inspire en repoussant le pouce on
inspire en gonflant le ventre puis le
thorax
bref on inspire en utilisant son
diaphragme
c'est le muscle inspirateur principal on
est fait pour respirer avec lui si on
s'en sert pas il va sans réduire se
contracter et il va tirer sur le bas de
notre dos on va se retrouver comme ça
et du coup pour voir ce qui se passe
autour de nous on va devoir relever la
tête de cette façon et du coup on va
avoir mal en bas du dos et aux
cervicales et dans ma profession
d'ostéopathe
je vois souvent des gens qui viennent
pour ce motif de consultation alors que
finalement il suffit de prendre le temps
et de prendre conscience qu'on peut
respirer comme ça avec notre diaphragme
en plus il est posé sur nos vies ses
abdominaux et donc quand on inspire en
gonflant le ventre on les compriment et
on fait ainsi remonter le sang veineux
vers le coeur qui va le redistribuer
ensuite dans tout le corps à son tour du
coup le diaphragme misère à respirer à
brasser de l'air et il participe à faire
circuler sans nous finalement ce
diaphragme c'est un peu le grand
animateur en plus en regardant dans les
dictionnaires on peut trouver pour
désigner la mpt notre essence des mots
comme anima en latin dont la racine est
le mot souffle ou en sanskrit le moana
pour respirer
donc notre essence est vraiment lié à
notre respiration des traditions
anciennes expliquent en plus que notre
corps c'est une flûte dans lequel
souffle notre âme
donc notre diaphragme ce grand animateur
il est vraiment centrale en plus de sa
position et je me dis que si nous
parlait il le ferait sans doute à la mat
à la manière du parrain s'est pas le
mois que vous vivez et c'est pas moi que
vous voulez j'ai détient les pouvoirs de
vie et de mort apprenez à me respecter
et soyez tranquilles
plusieurs études scientifiques corrobore
cette petite idée que je me suis fait et
qui nous montre qu'ils nous expliquent
que le yoga le tai chi ou encore le tchi
kong
bref des disciplines qu'ils nous
demandent une respiration lente profonde
et en conscience sont excellentes pour
notre santé et maintenant je vous invite
à voir une journée pour votre corps du
coup le matin encore couché on peut
commencer par dire pouce au réveil pour
lui demander un créneau d'une minute et
pendant 7 minutes
on va commencer par respirer normalement
avec le diaphragme et puis on peut
allonger alternativement les jambes pour
des comprimés le bas du dos une zone
qu'on retrouve souvent douloureuse et
usées vous savez avec cette fameuse
arthrose puits pour sortir du lit on va
plier les jambes et se tourner sur le
côté voilà c'est comme ça qu'on se lève
du bon pied
ensuite sous la douche ou dans sa
baignoire on peut s'habiller
plutôt que de faire de l'équilibrisme
sur un fond de savon et risquer de se
blesser
idem pour s'habiller on sort les habits
de l'armoire on les pose sur le lit et
on s'assoit pour s'habiller encore
récemment un patient expliqué que sa
belle mère est décédée des suites d'une
mauvaise chute en enfilant ses collants
donc par mais sa part en mémoire de
cette dame je vous demande de ne plus
oublier de votre côté en voiture souvent
par travaillent encore en voiture et
j'aimerais savoir qui parmi vous utilise
son appui tête
vous pouvez peut-être levé la main qui
est c'est une grande grande minorité
donc on va revoir ça ensemble donc une
fois dans la voiture
finalement c'est assez simple il suffit
de calais pied gauche sur le passage de
roue pour caler son bassin contre le
dossier du fauteuil un peu comme ça
et puis quand on est dans cette position
on peut poser la tête sur l'appuie-tête
et en plus on peut facilement respirer
parce que le diaphragme et libre alors
que si on lâche le pied qu'on avance le
bassin on va se retrouver un peu comme
ça et là difficile de respirer et c'est
comme ça qu'on se retrouve tressés en
voiture vient ensuite au bureau
au bureau on pas souvent la journée
ainsi hors part à 16 nous apprenait que
c'est la dose qui fait le poison donc
dans l'idéal on espère pouvoir changer
de position et c'est pour ça qu'il
existe des bureaux amovible qui passe de
boue vous qui nous permettent de varier
notre position dans la journée un peu
ainsi un peu de boue c'est déjà une
obligation légale danemark pour
l'employeur de proposer ce type
d'aménagement
en plus on a mis tellement d'années à
acquérir une bipédie stable que c'est
quand même dommage de régresser à une
position assise pour laquelle nous ne
sommes pas vraiment fait pour
fonctionner victor hugo thomas jefferson
sont deux exemples de personnes qui ont
plutôt bien travaillé et qui avait des
bureaux de boue puis vient l'heure du
déjeuner encore une fois on va s'asseoir
à table mais là vaut mieux manger assis
je pense et le moment clé ça va être de
mâcher de penser à mâcher mâché on peut
le faire cinq fois de chaque côté c'est
la fonction qui fait leurs gammes comme
nous disait gallien du coup d'utiliser
nos dents c'est ça qui va les renforcer
qui va aider la circulation du sang à
l'intérieur d'elle et en plus si le
boulot n'est pas fait parler dans
l'estomac ne va pas être très content il
va devoir sécréter plus d'acides ce qui
peut faire le terrain pour des brûlures
d'estomac
dermont ou des remontées acides et en
plus le travail chimique ne remplacera
pas le travail mécanique et du coup des
gros morceaux vont passer fermenter dans
l'intestin et nous transformer en
émetteur de gaz ou pas très à la mode
et enfin ce bon repas
ces aliments qui viennent du monde
extérieur on peut prendre le temps de
les garder en bouche comme un
préliminaire avant l'acte sexuel
histoire que notre corps s'y habitue
sinon si on avons mange trop vite c'est
juste un trou qu'on remplit
et maintenant la sieste la sieste en
france s'est encore vu comme un signe de
faiblesse
pourtant de nombreux leaders les gens
très productif font des siestes
ça devrait être je pense obligatoires en
plus il ya plein encore d'études
scientifiques qui disent que la
productivité et surtout la créativité
est amélioré par les siestes et dans
notre époque de dictature des sociétés
transnationales
je pense qu'on va avoir besoin d'être
créatif paient déjà cédric villani qui
pratique une sieste lui à même le sol et
il explique un détail croustillant pour
l'ostéopathe que je suis que à même le
sol son corps y participent et que ça
leur source en profondeur à un autre
niveau
on à bertrand piccard qui pendant son
odyssée à travers le solar inc pulse
pratiques et de courtes périodes
d'autohypnose les périodes de 36 me
hypnotique qui lui permettaient de vite
récupérer pendant ces longues heures de
vol et j'adore sa citation d'arrêter de
se battre contre les vents de la vie car
elle fait elle est évidemment
polysémique elle renvoie à plein de
choses et notamment à cette capacité de
s'abandonner de se relâcher de lâcher
prise pour faire la sieste ou
expérimenter la transe hypnotique
et puis l'après midi on a souvent des
choses à porter en tout cas on en a tous
et pour ça il faut bien penser le même
si on soulève des briques vous départ
par notre dos ce n'est pas une grue
non on n'est pas fait pour se relever de
cette position après on peut bricoler un
peu comme ça mais surtout ramener le
bassin sous la tête pour se relever
ensuite plus ça peut être une bonne
solution pour les gens qui peuvent pas
mettre un genou à terre ou qui ne
peuvent pas s'asseoir sur leurs talons
une bonne alternative aussi ça peut être
la fente parce que dans cette position
le bassin est mobile et du coup on peut
se pencher se relever comme ça sans
risquer de se blesser et enfin le soir
on peut prévoir un petit dîner aux
chandelles une petite anse une
expression verticale pour un désir
horizontale on se caresse le dos on se
caresse les bras en plein là où l'on
trouve les récepteurs aux fibres c'est
et qui vont stimuler notre insu là et ça
messieurs le cerveau en entier c'est le
premier organe sexuel de la femme et
c'est insula plus précisément stimulé
par quelques simples caresses pas
sécrété de l'ocytocine vous savez le
site hocine cette hormone de l'amour de
l'attachement qu'on va sécréter un petit
peu quand on est avec des amis un peu
plus quand on est avec notre amoureux ou
notre amoureuse et en cascade au moment
d'un orgasme
donc pour résumer le matin on pense à se
lever du bon pied
on s'assoit pour la douche et pour
s'habiller dans la voiture on pense à
l'appuie tête pour pouvoir respirer
au bureau on varie les plaisirs
assis ou debout à table on pense à
mâcher cinq fois de chaque côté pour
soulever des charges
on pense à la fente au genou plié et le
soir caresses du dos caresses des
avant-bras stimulation de l'insula voilà
vous avez le mode d'emploi
à vous d'en faire un mode de vie aussi
fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]